sometimes it's more possible
for people who have not been at the helm
to make changes for the better
because they aren't hide bound to
tradition or
socially and culturally encouraged to
stick to
conventional practices
[Music]
tomcat ranch is a learning laboratory
where we produce healthy
foods on fertile soils through
regenerative ranching
in a way that inspires others to action
regenerative ranching is a way of
practicing
agriculture that harnesses the natural
systems and cycles like the carbon
solar and water cycles
we're practicing regenerative ranching
with a
herd of cattle 120 head who live here on
the ranch from birth
till the day they leave for harvesting
and we're managing them according to a
holistic management process
so as we're managing the cattle we're
moving them
often to mimic how wild herds
move through the wild grasslands
and we're measuring as we go using
our on-site scientific partners
point blue who do ecological evaluation
and monitoring
for us grazing operations are important
to
societal benefit and they if done poorly
can
create quite a lot of societal harm i
think
anybody who takes a close look at the
confined animal factory operations
method of raising cattle and other
livestock
would be horrified to see what they find
there from a moral standpoint
but it is also deeply unsustainable
and whether we eat meat or not we need
ungulates
those are cattle and other animals that
can convert
cellulosic fiber to biomass which is
really
converting solar energy into food
but at the same time that they're doing
that they're also
building top soils if no one ever ate a
speck of meat again
we still would want to graze the lands
with ungulates so that we maintain
topsoils
for all those row crops that go into
plant-based proteins
i'm not the practitioner on the land but
i'm more the cheerleader for everything
that goes on here
professional land managers manage the
ranch
typically people talk about one thing in
a regenerative agriculture we talk about
all things about healthy food healthy
water healthy climate
healthy biodiversity healthy soil
healthy rural communities and it's
putting all those together and we're
trying to
rebuild the system one of the hard
things is getting people excited about
it
because agriculture is a business that
it's hard has so many variables to
contemplate
is something that we really work hard to
figure out what are the things
what are the studies or what are the
examples
who are the heroes in the business that
we can share
we seek racial and gender diversity in
all of the activities that we engage in
sometimes i put it that we need to put
more
and different people in charge because
those groups who have been left out of
power structures
for so long those groups often have the
best
insights into how to overcome oppression
and disinvestment and we should be
listening to them but also putting them
in power
what motivates me to do all of the work
that i'm so lucky to get to do
stems from my first memory at the age of
five
we all watched television as jfk's
funeral rolled by
and subsequently we watched the funerals
of bobby kennedy martin luther king
and i even imagined that i saw malcolm
x's funeral which i don't believe was
televised
as a child i understood from the
solemnity of those events that something
was
terribly wrong in american society and
it stemmed from our origins
in african enslavement jim crow
mass incarceration native genocide and
land theft
persecution of immigrants and refugees
less than personhood for women
extreme environmental degradation all of
these things weighed
on my conscience at a very early age
and i have spent a lifetime trying to
find a way to be helpful
in writing all those wrongs
i hope tomcat ranch has been able to be
influential
in migrating millions of acres of our
grazing lands to regenerative ranching
through collaboration with many many
other parties and networks and
organizations
we really are attempting to be a
beneficial
contributor to a community of practice
around regenerative agriculture
and together i think we can achieve the
co-benefits
you